cctv from a restaurant captured peter r
davis
in the moments before he was critically
injured walking from a television studio
down a quiet amsterdam street
[Music]
then the sound of five gunshots are
heard
one of the shots hit the journalist in
the head
as he lay in hospital the many in this
city who knew him
and his work well came to the street in
shock and sadness
willing and praying for him to recover
he was doing things which
other people are afraid to do so
that's a big big compliment for him
sad about my city also that it's
happened here in our city and
you don't feel safe anymore mr darice is
one of the netherlands best known and
respected crime journalists
widely fated for his reporting on drug
and criminal gangs
he worked with the police in major
investigations and as a result
his life had been threatened he's a very
famous
crime reporter from the last maybe
three or four decades
so he was involved in very big cases
cases where murders were murder cases
were unsolved
and he helped with the help of the
public with his tv program
to solve those cases to help to get
someone convicted
you make some enemies just before the
attack mr dufrese had appeared on a chat
show on dutch television
mr dufrese had gained many enemies over
the years but police are likely to focus
on associates
of an alleged drug lord currently on
trial in holland
the journalist was acting as a counselor
and advisor to a key state witness
whose own brother and lawyer were
murdered
whoever was responsible for the shooting
those who've studied the dutch
underworld of drugs and violence
say it is sophisticated and ruthless and
the attack would have been a very public
message
against a reporter who has taken on the
criminals
so it's what happens not for the first
time in the netherlands
when a criminal group feels so powerful
or
has people so disposable to use
and to dispose of that they don't care
about the consequences
mr davis remains critically ill a
journalist made famous by reporting on
the kind of violence
he appears to have become victim to
himself
michelle clifford sky news amsterdam